[Music]
hello everyone
in the previous videos we have seen how
the bending
and the stretching that comes out as
completely decoupled
and we had emphasized that that is a
little bit problematic
because uh if we consider our axial load
to just change in sign so that instead
of an
axial tensile load it is an axial
compressive load
then also as our theory predicts
the bending and the stretching even
though this can be considered as
negative stretching the compression that
will come out to be completely decoupled
and the problem uh therein
is that we know for a fact from our
physical understanding as well as from
our undergraduate studies
of mechanics of solids or mechanics of
materials that when you have
compression of a beam or a bar
or a column or a rod whatever you want
to say
beyond a certain critical value of the
compressive force
the uh the rod
is going to buckle so the theory that we
have in our hand till now
that is unable to capture this
phenomenon of buckling
and the the key thing to
understand to identify the problem here
is that
buckling is basically an instability
phenomenon
okay so buckling does show up in the
form of the bending
but it is different from bending in the
sense that
it is an instability phenomenon so this
is very important point
now uh whenever we have to capture uh
such a
such an instability in the buckling
or or in the form of buckling we have to
have a non-linear
ingredient in our theory okay so this is
the
key missing link uh from our theory
from our from our current theory that we
do not have anything non-linear whether
you take
the kinematical hypothesis or you take
the strain displacement relations
all of them are linear and that is where
the problem is
okay so we have to incorporate a
non-linear ingredient in our theory
so that we can capture the phenomenon
of buckling so towards that end what we
are going to do is we
we are going to keep the kinematical
hypothesis as the same
okay so right now i am not drawing any
particular figure
but you understand that
well i mean i can have a figure a
generic figure like this
that
so i have
i have a beam or a rados anything
and i have axial load
okay axial load load in the compressive
sense
so again you note that i have not
restricted to any particular boundary
conditions
but unlike unlike the previous videos i
am not considering any lateral load here
so this is under pure compression
and what we want to capture is that this
beam
uh would buckle under
a certain value or beyond a certain
value of this compressive force that is
the thing that we want to capture
through our theory
so as i was mentioning our kinematical
hypothesis will remain the same
as before
so our u is still
u s minus z
dw dx v is equal to 0
and w is equal to
w x so w is a pure function of x okay
which is why i have written here
directly as d w t x
instead of del w delta x okay so this is
our kinematical hypothesis exactly the
same as before
but as i was mentioning we have to
introduce some kind of nonlinear
ingredient and that nonlinear ingredient
we are going to introduce in in the
strain displacement relations
[Music]
okay
this is where the non-linearity is
introduced
now all of us are very familiar with the
with the linear strain displacement
relations but
for students enrolled in this course all
of you have
uh have studied the non-linear strain
displacement relations
either in the undergraduate mechanics of
solids course
or in the previous course in of applied
elasticity
so if you do not remember that i suggest
that you please go and take a look back
at the uh at the appropriate videos from
the kinematics chapter of applied
elasticity
okay so if you look back there
uh
the uh the e
x x and please note that i'm writing
this with a capital e
you denote that i'm going to use the
non-linear
relation so here the expression is
del u del x this term is very much
present in the linear
screen also but in addition i have these
terms
so i urge all of you to please take a
look back
at those relations okay so similarly
i can keep on writing this e y y
terms like this and e z said
and so on and so forth okay i'm not
going to write those down
now before we can proceed any further
it is extremely important to note that
now we are going to invoke
a very important uh
simplifying assumption if this
simplifying assumption is basically
following
from a physical understanding of the
problem and
the important assumption here
is that
del w del x this is going to be much
larger
than del u del x okay so
now you know that in this expression the
v of course it
since v itself is 0 this doesn't bother
us
but what about the comparison between
del u del x and del w del x so here
it is here that our important assumption
is going to play a role
so that our e x
x that is going to be
del u del x
plus half
delta x square okay now
please do not be worried by the fact
that
uh while
this is true then what about this
compared with this
so see it's something like this that uh
your del w del x it is larger than
del u del x certainly but these itself
are very small quantities
so if you take the square of that
if you take the square of that then it
becomes kind of comparable with the
del u del x okay so for example
for example if you uh if you consider
the del u del x to be something like
0.01
and the del w del x to be 0.1 then you
know that
this is one order of magnitude larger
than this the delta w del x is one order
of magnitude larger than this del u del
x
but when you take the square of this del
w del x then it becomes 0.01
and then it becomes comparable with this
delu del x and it would not be right to
neglect this in comparison with this so
it is in that sense that we are writing
this
okay now already we have an expression
from our kinematical hypothesis
regarding this u
so we can write that down okay so this
is basically
d u s d x
minus z d squared w
dx square plus half
dw dx whole squared and please note how
i have written this
in terms of ordinary derivatives instead
of partial derivatives because
the only variation is with respect to x
now uh what you are going to see is that
or what we are going to consider is that
this e x x is going to be the dominant
uh term uh yeah i mean you can go and
check for yourself like what happens to
this e y y
z all of those things uh so
let me not invest any more time on those
uh you can check for yourself
uh what i will do is i'll immediately
launch into
uh the the business
of deriving the governing equations for
for the situation uh for that for the
deflection
uh considering both the u.s and the w
uh and what i'll be doing unlike the
previous
videos is that i will not go separately
into
the use of the principle of stationary
potential energy
and then the use of the principle of
virtual work
rather i'll do it in one single shot
by using the principle of virtual work
okay
so let me go to the next slide and
use the principle
which will work
okay so we know uh from our earlier
discussions
that the general expression that we are
going to deal with
uh will be like this
and where i have just taken care to
replace the epsilon i j
with a capital e i j
the right hand side remains the same
it's a multiplication of the fraction
vector with the
first variation of the displacement
vector integrated over the entire
surface
all right so for the left hand side
what we are going to have is uh
because we are dealing with uh with a
beam
so uh i'm going to make direct use
of the things that i have discussed
earlier
so this volume integral i'm going to
write
in terms of this integration over the
length and integration over the height
uh and since there's going to be
no variation along the on the width i'll
just get a
get a b out of that okay where b is the
width of the beam
okay so what i have here
is sigma xx
delta e xx so these are the dominant
contributions
so this is dz
dx okay
and this sigma xx it's
um i made a mistake here so this
e should not be appearing here
it is only in the about that
it is only in the next step here
when i replace the sigma xx by e
e xx okay that we are going to have this
e now uh i can understand that there
will be a little bit of a confusion
up because of the same kind of letters
being used so this capital e
with the subscript xx that represents
the non-linear strain in the x direction
and this e capital e it represents the
young's modulus
okay we just have to be a little bit
careful
okay so now
[Music]
what i'm going to do is just replace
this expression for uh
of e x x from what i had obtained in the
previous slide
so basically this this thing
so this is uh i can even copy this thing
out from here
so this is our exxx and for the next one
i have this first variation of the exxx
for that
what i'm going to do is
write down the expression directly
now see for this term half del d w d x
square
if i take the first variation of that
it's going to be
t w d x
d delta w
d x
all right now uh because of what we have
discussed earlier
i'm going to simplify or
or cut short some of the intermediate
steps
and if you have been following through
in the previous videos
uh then they should not be any problem
now the strategy that i'm going to
follow is
this this term d u s d x
together with this half d w d x square
these two
are independent of z similarly these two
these two are independent of z
so i am considering them together okay
and then
i'll carry out the multiplication of
these
two simple brackets okay
so that multiplied
by these two terms taken together
now this is the part where i'm going to
cut short the the simplifications or or
the intermediate steps a little bit
uh you note that
uh when i take this two terms
okay basically this one that multiplied
with this
which has as its coefficient is the z
and then subsequently i
i carry out the integration with respect
to z what is going to happen is that
z being an odd function uh
in this situation it is going to give me
a zero
similarly when i when i multiply this
z d square w d x square with
this term which is present here this one
and this one then
the result of that integration because
of z being an odd function that is going
to give me
zero terms okay so i'll get
zero terms here
okay zero terms means
uh terms which are zero in value
and then i'm i'm going to obtain
uh or maybe i can just
save some space by not writing this word
terms
just writing a 0 here okay
uh and then i'll have the multiplication
between uh this one and this one so that
is going to give me
uh z squared
d squared w e x squared
d squared delta w dx square
right so this entire thing
so maybe it was just battery file
if i separate out the integration
all right
okay so uh i have considerably
shortened my intermediate steps now
now what i do is uh
is actually deal with these terms
okay there is no getting away from this
so you see
uh first of all you note that
this entire thing and this and that
thing that is independent of
z similarly e is independent of z p is
independent of z
so i can take all of these things out of
this integration with respect to
the z and that is going to
basically leave me with an integration
from minus
h by 2 to h by 2 dz and that is just
nothing but h itself okay
so in a similar fashion i can take this
e b and the d square w d x square d
square delta w d x squared
out of this integration with respect to
z and that will leave me an integration
from minus h by 2 to h by 2
z squared d z and the result of that b
multiplied with that integration with
respect to z is nothing but i
so we have seen all of these things in
our earlier videos
so now again i'm going to cut short that
card short those writing
in between and directly write the uh
write the expressions here
okay so uh let me just go ahead and
and do that uh in the next slide
so what i can do here is uh
maybe copy this part
i'm just adjust facing here a little bit
okay i think i'm happy with that uh
so this is integration with respect to x
and then uh
i have
the e i d squared w d
x squared d squared
delta w d x
again this integration is with respect
to x from zero to
l okay so uh
i might as well have written this up
here okay so
just to save some space uh it's much
easier to do this
on a chalkboard uh this is the first
time i'm doing this on a writing app so
forgive the
uh
i have that business in which i'm
cutting and pasting here and there
all right now uh
what do we do from here you see uh
this entire thing that we have okay this
entire
thing that we have uh
this is let us not forget that this is
just the left hand side
of uh of our original uh equation
which uh which
which has its origin at the principle of
virtual work
okay so uh
the right hand side that is going to
incorporate the contributions
from p so what i'm saying here is this
that i'm dealing with the lhs here
the addages uh this fraction this will
be contributed
by the force p and you please note that
this delta u i
it will ultimately give me terms
involving things like delta u s
okay so just like before my motivation
here
is somehow to convert these integration
this integration which involves this
d dx of delta u s here and also the d dx
of delta w
that in terms of of
through the through the integration by
parts in terms of delta u s
and delta w without involving the first
derivatives
okay so towards that end what i'll do is
i'll just subdivide or
i'll just multiply this thing out uh
and consider this uh separately now from
from now on because i do not have to do
any
operations of at least for the next few
steps
on this term what i'll do is this entire
thing
i'll just write in short
as this curly bracket okay so whatever
was present here
okay so that i'm writing as this curly
bracket okay just to
just to reduce some space and and and
decrease the time of writing
this is something that i actually do
when i'm writing on the chalkboard also
uh and somehow i feel that the students
find it much easier to keep track of the
various terms if i write like this
okay so trust me it's it's better this
way uh however
whatever the remaining terms are then
i'll write in full because that is where
i have to do my operations okay
so i have this um
next i have again
this term underlined with the white
color uh
basically this here
and this multiplied with dwtx
d delta w dx
dx and whatever is remaining here
this is a familiar term right from our
our
uh our one of the first videos of this
beam theory
up and we can we can actually uh
very quickly write down the integration
by parts terms from this but we will do
that later on for now we just keep it
like this
okay
all right so now we do the integration
by parts
so
we keep it like this and after one
integration we'll have this
so this contributes to the boundary
terms
and then we'll have this integration 0
to l
now we have to take the ddx of this
entire thing
which is ea
early bracket this thing
and then delta us
all right similarly for this term here
uh i'll have
e a curly bracket whatever is present
inside here
ewtx and then delta w
contributing to the boundary terms
and then i'll have minus
minus integration
0 to l d dx
now this is very important to note that
when you are doing the integration by
parts over here
this entire part okay so
this entire part that we are going to
take
up as the first term of the integration
by parts
okay so
we have this from the previous line
but together with this
and whatever is left is this enter w
so just to mark it off uh clearly
this is what we are doing here
okay now from this
from this last term uh what we are going
to have
is
e i u squared w
d x squared and the
delta w dx this contributes
to the boundary terms
and now i'm going to write this thing in
one shot
okay so i'm not going to carry out the
integration by parts twice
separately rather i'm going to do the
integration by parts twice
in one shot okay so i am skipping
another step here
all right so all of this together that
constitutes
my left hand side okay
now for the right hand side
what i'm going to have is
minus p delta u s
at x equal to l please note that
this minus p occurring at x equal to l
is present because the
the direction of the applied load at p
is opposite to the positive direction of
x
let me clarify what i mean by that you
see the p
is op is directed in this right to left
here so if i am considering my x
direction
to be like this this
force p here which has a magnitude p
and the algebraic sign for that will be
with a minus
so that is what i have written there
okay next
this is
plus p this is for
the end at x equal to zero
and of course uh i'll have extra terms
if i have uh if i have the
i have any uh q load okay so
just to keep things very general i'll
have things like this
so maybe i can just go back here and
make it more general this diagram more
general
by incorporating
in case i have loads like this also
present lateral loads also present
then that is what is going to be there
if i have things like this then that is
also going to contribute
to the right hand side
okay now uh you check for once that this
is indeed my left hand side
i want just to clarify this is my left
hand side continued from the previous
page
so as uh so what i have here
is terms involving the delta u is in the
boundary terms
nowhere else in the boundary terms so my
boundary terms are those
uh this one this one this one this one
so it is only in this term that i have
the presence of this delta us
okay so uh here also i have a delta u s
in the boundary term this i can write of
course
as uh
minus p delta u s
0 and l
and this this one just remains as it is
okay now
this this term involving the
the integration with the coefficient of
this delta u is in the integrand
this doesn't have any any counterpart in
another
integral term okay so this is going to
contribute
to the uh to one of the governing
differential equations
next for uh for the boundary terms
involving the
delta w i have this term
uh i also have this term this is
separate
because it is involving the first
derivative of delta w
so now whatever i'm saying now is
basically following from
our knowledge of calculus of variations
uh basically how the
euler lagrange equations emerge and the
corresponding boundary
uh conditions so
what we can do is we can directly go
ahead
and write down our
our governing equations and boundary
conditions from here
[Music]
governing equations
the first governing equation will be the
coefficient of
this delta u s term from this
integration term
so that is d d x
of e a i'm continuing with this
writing of this curly bracket and you'll
see
uh what is the benefit of this okay i
uh
right the other uh
governing equation uh
that i'm going to have please note that
i have worry about here so this is a dx
here
the other governing equation that i'm
going to have
is as the coefficient of this delta w
term so you see
i have one term here and i have another
term here
okay so let me write that down
this is minus
ddx
ea value bracket
ewtx close bracket
and this term which is the coefficient
of another delta w
all right and on the right hand side let
us not forget that there is another
integration term
involving the delta w so all the
coefficients of the delta w considering
only the integration terms that we are
collecting together
as one governing equation okay
that is exactly the same thing what we
had done for the separate variable
us it it is just simpler looking
compared to the second equation because
you see there is no other
integration term involving the delta u s
okay so much about the governing
equations now what about the boundary
condition
conditions so
what what we're going to say is that at
x equal to 0
and x equal to l
you see first of all i have to consider
this term okay so all the other
boundary terms they involve
the uh the w
variable here if we have delta w uh
here we have um
here we have the first derivative of
delta w again there is the
delta w present here so this is about
the left hand side
but on the right hand side you note that
i do have a
boundary term involving the delta u s so
what i have to do is i have to consider
this
together with this that's exactly what
i'm going to do
so at x equal to 0 and at x equal to l
up what i'm going to have is either
so when i write the either i'll
basically take the coefficient
of this delta u s and this delta u s
so this e a curly bracket
that is going to be equal to minus p
or as i have written
quite a few times earlier the us
is going to be specified if either it
has to be specified
or this thing must be true ea curly
bracket whatever is present inside is
should be equal to minus p so that is
considering the the delta u s terms next
i also have to write down the terms
involving the delta w
so i have this thing a curly bracket
dwds
again either
ea curly bracket
dwtx
that is just one term
involving the delta w there is another
term involving the delta w
so the coefficient of that is minus e i
d cube w
d x cubed
so either that has to be equal to 0
or w
must be specified
finally i must not forget that there is
another
term in the boundary which is this
involving the first derivative of the
delta w
okay so
and the coefficient of there that is
this e i t squared w t x
square so
eid square w dx square that should be
equal to 0
or it is the dwdx
which should be specified
you please note that because in this
boundary term
i have the presence of this d delta w dx
what i'm doing
is taking this delta outside and
considering the first variation of this
dwdx okay and that is why i am
concluding
that if dw dx is specified then
automatically the first variation of
that
that is delta dw dx must be zero
okay so i have all these boundary
conditions
and this two sets of governing equations
and
uh the situation seems rather hopeless
at this point
that if uh i mean if you have studied
buckling in your undergraduate days
surely you did not have to deal with so
many equations
uh probably you you came across
something like the
uh very famous euler buckling criterion
and probably you you had some kind of a
hand waving
derivation of that and
everyone was quite happy with that but
surely you did not have to deal with
two such governing equations and these
all these boundary conditions so what
exactly is going on
okay so we'll see uh in the
in the next video how the situation can
be
somewhat simplified but not too much
okay
we can reduce the
the necessary or the required governing
differential equation
to only one equation from this two set
and there will be some corresponding
simplifications in the boundary
conditions
okay but ultimately the the equation
that we'll have
uh that will be a general enough
equation uh
quite a general equation not the
absolutely general equation
or addressing buckling okay so on that
note let me end this
video thank you very much